hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 12 video a whole
bunch of stuff happened so I'll try to
explain all the new characters and
what's going on especially the big twist
at the end the big post-credits scene
this is probably gonna be the closest
we'll ever get to a musical episode a
lot of the main cast members have
musical backgrounds either either on
television or as actual musical artists
Stephen Amell has the funniest answers
when people ask them if they're ever
gonna do a musical episode of arrow his
answers are usually along the lines of
never and over my dead body
okay so just careful for spoilers from
the episode I'm gonna start with
explainers for the characters that we
just met in the episode like the brand
new characters first up is Picabo she's
actually a character that Jeff John's
created in the comics horror stories
pretty close to what it is in the comics
as well as what her character does she
has a boyfriend who's in prison she
helps him break out and he convinces her
to use her ability to steal money she's
one of those characters that's
relatively new and doesn't get used a
lot so she doesn't have the long history
that a lot of the other rogues like
Captain Colt and heatwave have she is
really useful for teeing up the idea of
toxic relationships she's still in love
with clay Parker probably needs to get
over him Caitlin snow still in love with
Ronnie Raymond probably needs to get
over him I always talk about narrative
symmetry so think about what's going on
with peek-a-boos relationship and what
it might say about the future of Caitlin
snow and the firestorm relationship how
that might develop Caitlin's probably
gonna get raked over the coals so to
speak next up on the list is Linda Park
in the comics she's mostly known as the
wife of Wally west of the Wally West
flash obviously the show's playing with
the timeline just a little bit they are
gonna do Wally West at some point but
it's gonna be closer to the new 52 Wally
West he'll be an african-american in
just because she's going out with Barry
now it doesn't mean she won't ultimately
get married to Wally West in the future
if he didn't recognize her the actors
playing her is melis Chow I feel like
she did a really good job she was really
only a small part of this episode but
we're gonna see her more in the next
couple of episodes like they'll develop
that character she and iris West can
totally Duke it out as to which female
flash family member gets speedforce
powers first yes there have been times
in the comics when iris West and Linda
Park have had Speed Force powers I don't
think they're gonna do anything close to
that this season but just keep that in
the back of your mind
it is possible that we could get a
female speedster at some point then
obviously the last big introduction
gorilla grodd like full-on gorilla grodd
I've already done an explainer video for
him so I'll just all I had a link in the
description basically they are bringing
him on full steam ahead really what you
need to know is that gorilla grodd in
the comics is fairly evil so he'll be
one of the more angry villains that
we'll see on the show okay so moving on
to top five moments number five the
flash is learning to use his abilities
in new ways like they said at the
beginning he's getting faster
progressively faster and he's learning
new ways to use his speed for its power
to help people him vibrating his hands
on the door to open it that's gonna be a
precursor to him you know flat-out
vibrating through walls I do think we'll
see that this season if we're gonna see
time travel we'll probably see him face
through a wall for those that haven't
seen any of the news they've been pretty
open about the time-travel stuff I think
that's episode 17 it's the first episode
that the new weather wizard is gonna be
in it'll be like an accidental time
travel situation so I'll talk more about
it whenever that episode gets here
moving on to number four Barry's dad
does some detective work the really cool
thing about John Wesley Shipp helping
out in the episode is that it means that
he might be able to get more scenes in
future episodes or future seasons inside
the prison
it gives his character more places to go
and it gave them some really nice scenes
if my son were the flash I'd be really
proud of him I know everyone's hoping
that he'll like secretly turn out to be
Jay Garrick or something like that they
could totally do some weird storyline
where he gets temporary Speed Force
powers but that's kind of outlandish I
think his storyline will be more of this
until they clear him of the murder
he's gonna have more Prison Break scenes
make as many jokes about that as you
want this episode in general just ended
up turning into a kind of a Prison Break
episode Pied Piper broke out of prison
peekaboo broke her boyfriend clay Parker
out of prison that's gonna happen more
and more the more people they lock up
the more people will escape which is
actually nice intro to number three Pied
Piper explains firestorm
there were actually a couple things
going on with this pipe piper storyline
one he got away which means he could
show up in a future episode what I'm
hoping for is that they'll do something
close to the first appearance of Gorilla
Grodd in the comics Grodd goes on a
rampage in the city Pied Piper helps
team flash take him down
Hartley's been kind of a dick so far so
I don't know if he's gonna help him out
but it would be really cool to see him
in that gorilla grodd episode as he said
though he totally held up his end of the
bargain they see footage of what
happen to Ronnie Raymond and Professor
Martin Stein I like that freaky looking
shot of Robbie Mills face it just looks
so scary they kind of explained it in
the post-credits scene that the next
episode is gonna be them trying to
separate Ronnie from Professor Martin
Stein they're trying to like deactivate
firestorm so to speak moving on to
number two
Snowberry karaoke night like I said
probably the closest we'll ever get to a
musical episode I'm not really big on
stuff like that but but I love it when
they can have fun for just a few minutes
if you're not familiar with it they were
singing the song from grease summer
lovin they're both trying to find new
relationships and I think what's
developing at least what I saw
is sort of a reverse olicity situation
told from the female's perspective so if
you're not familiar with olicity you
have Oliver Queen in love with Felicity
but can't be with her purse Stephen
amell's explanation she is unattainable
it's like an unattainable thing it's
never gonna happen at least the way that
the fandom wants it to so I think the
same situation is gonna develop between
Barry and Caitlin snow she'll develop
those olicity type feelings for Barry
the look on her face at the end whenever
she was thinking about it that's what
sold me on it
just think of the emotional havoc that's
gonna wreak whenever a firestorm comes
back into the narrative because there
will be a ton of firestorm to the back
half of the season you guys can let me
know what you think but is it Barry that
she is developing feelings for or is it
some mystery person that we haven't met
yet
my favorite performer this week though
danielle panabaker hands down as caitlin
snow she was a force of nature
she is rapidly outpacing felicity smoak
is my favorite female character in the
DC arrow universe on TV right now to be
fair though danielle Panabaker has been
one of my favorite like genre actresses
for a long time who else remembers sky
high is like she graduated from that
superhero school and went to work at
STAR Labs it totally fits within that
metahuman universe like the flash TV
show is a sky-high sequel Saved by the
Bell two college years and moving on to
my number one moment
Grodd lives so full disclosure I knew we
were gonna get Gorilla Grodd really soon
did not know we would see him at the end
of this episode I was scanning my
Twitter feed for news and I saw it Greg
Berlanti tweeted be sure to watch
tonight's flash if you like giant
gorillas and I was just like wait what I
can't remember off the top of my head it
might be episode 14 or 15
but Grodd will be in like a full-on
episode broad daylight running around
being crazy based on the special effects
in this episode it makes me really
hopeful for the future of the series if
they can do special effects like this on
the cheap and it looks this good then
that means they'll be able to do all
kinds of crazy super powers here's my
big question for you guys given what
they've done with Gorilla Grodd so far
where would you like to see them to take
that character so what'd you guys think
about that just to talk about some of
the easter eggs that I haven't already
mentioned so I've already talked about
Linda Park Wally West Gorilla Grodd
there was the line that Barry Allen had
I guess I'm faster than a speeding
bullet
that's another diggeth Superman
technically the flash is faster than
Superman
but that's only because he can break the
laws of physics I know it sounds silly
but the Speed Force is the reason why he
isn't subject to friction all in all
great episode I didn't have any
significant thumbs down the peekaboo
stuff at the beginning with the
telescope that was a little bit silly
but the character is a little bit silly
so there being true to the comics the
flash in general week to week has some
of the strongest scripts of any of the
DC comic book TV shows on tomorrow arrow
is actually gonna kind of continue this
crazy energy this crazy party vibe there
will be an all-out Throwdown in the
glades so if you haven't seen the clip
we found out Malcolm merlyn's wife was
murdered by brick so Merlyn is gonna go
apeshit there's some other awesome stuff
happening that I don't want to spoil but
be sure to subscribe to get my video up
I'll post it after the episode tomorrow
and yes I will do an arrow flash Q&A
this week so don't worry about that I
know a lot of people have been asking
okay so while you guys wait for all that
to happen you can click here to learn
more about Gorilla Grodd from the comics
if you haven't seen that video yet I
just do an explainer for his history in
the comics and you can click here to get
ready for arrow thank you so much for
watching so let's all high-five I'll see
you guys tonight
you